in this film you are on a horse and was
that again was your idea was it another
vision yes I had another vision after
chapter 2 John wick is running out of
Central Park and I said Chad I have a
vision it was like what y'all knew and I
said I want to ride a horse
why don't I ride a horse I'm trying to
escape and so he said that's a good idea
and so began the training because with
John wick he can't just ride a horse
ya have to come off the saddle you're
supposed to fall under it held onto the
pommel excuse me
it's fine and then I couldn't really do
it and I fell well as you do and so then
they had to create something to make it
safe and so they did this contraption
that was like this truck with some beams
and then a gentleman on a wire so I was
picked in case I fell off the horse
while we were on the streets and so that
happened a couple times the horse took
off and I was like falling and then they
pulled me up and but uh so that was nice
I tell you who wouldn't have liked this
this forum Jamie Bell you're not you're
not a fan of the horse I didn't listen I
didn't love horses men are certain
particularly to get a long rim like I'd
be walking through a I mean not randomly
walking through a field but like I'd be
close to a horse like oh no I'm not no
that guy's giving me energy and it would
like run away because it would feel my
fear I was terrified of them you know
they're big and they're invincible never
connected over this I was I was thrown
from one on the set of Robin Hood you
know and I I got through a whole movie
about Robin Hood and I never once got on
a horse on camera actually if you never
on horseback I was never on a horse in a
pom wow what because I couldn't I
couldn't bear to I couldn't be within
like ten weeks you had them thrown off
I'm great yeah well now but then you
stopped Jamie because you had a special
was a woman or maybe a person anyway
name is Camilla Anna preusse and she
does she she does the kind of horse
mastery on a lot of film she's the horse
master on Game of Thrones like she's
done everything she has a very specific
technique which is kind of like strap
you onto the horse and she's with you on
another horse and she just kind of
starts going like I don't really like
this it's all and then she goes quicker
and quickly no seriously stop
and then she'll ask you incredibly
personal questions
your life how was your farm well tell me
about your father
like what do you feel most guilty about
and then ultimately you're like what
took cigarettes to school and my teacher
let me off like and you realize I've
totally forgotten about horse riding and
it was a crazy kind of therapeutic
amazing way of learning to ride a horse
I don't know yeah you will ride you ride
I love riding horse and ice that I went
to like every week fic I never would
have admitted that I won't ride horses
had I known that his story
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you